through snow-filled trenches they make
their way past the most exposed areas in
near silence
the front lines of this conflict in
ukraine are fixed but the fighting is a
constant
it is very dangerous and it certainly
feels it
they've been in these trenches for years
whatever the rising tensions outside
nothing here in the mud and snow
actually changes
although an invasion would of course
change everything this brigade guards
the southern flank of the ukrainian
army's front line with russian-backed
separatists in the east of the country
amongst their ranks are two
professionally contracted soldiers
foreign fighters who've joined up
unusually johnny wood and sean pinner
are from england
yeah this is my old position back in
2019 then
both say they've started new lives here
which is why they're fighting and then
the tree line over there's the uh enemy
position
i'm married a ukrainian i've got every
much right to be here and the guys it's
taken me a long time to integrate here
uh
so the guys know i'm not
you know a war tourist or a war junkie
and i'm with an organised unit i'm with
the government and i'm with a contracted
soldier i've integrated so they know i'm
not just uh like i said uh just sitting
around and i've got to go home at the
end of it i've been here my family's
here my family is 15 kilometers i can
hear the shelling from my front room
sean is a section commander here but
he's realistic about what may lie ahead
if they come across the ball that we're
out gunned we haven't got air supporting
honestly a superior superiority uh we
don't have a naval fleet very strong
naval fleet
uh but
ukrainians fight so we'll give them a
bloody nose that's for sure
johnny wood is on his third rotation he
says the west needs to help i don't
think we need to send british troops or
american troops i think all the west
needs to do is we need to support
ukraine politically like give them as
much political support as we're doing
like continue even like amp it up
and just give them the weapons they need
to defend themselves and to defend their
country
the ukrainian army has improved a lot
since 2014 but it's infinitely outgunned
by the russians
there used to be a brigade of foreign
fighters but that's been disbanded and
they've been assimilated into the
ukrainian army however it's quite clear
that volunteers do want to come from
abroad as this whole incident has grown
we understand a hundred vets from the
united states are on their way they'll
do some training in kiev before they
come to the front line
the british prime minister like many
others is warning that an invasion would
provoke a bloody battle akin to the
chechen wars
with thousands killed and whole
communities destroyed
on the shores of the azov sea lies the
town of shuriken
destroyed in the fighting and abandoned
in 2015.
scenes like these are exactly why
embassy staff are being evacuated
this could so easily happen again
and likely will if efforts to reach a
compromise fail
we're right on the edge now
stuart ramsey sky news eastern ukraine